now let's take this a little bit further  imagine if you sent that message to your  mum she jumps in the car hits the  nitrous button and drives like dominic  toretto unfortunately she's dominic  toretto in the first movie and that  train clips the side of her car the  brand new iphone 14 has inbuilt crash  detection which will automatically send  an sos emergency signal to allow  emergency services to come to her rescue  the moral of the story is if you're  going to buy yourself an iphone make  sure you buy your mum one if you want to  see the full video and all things  architecture related make sure you hit  that subscribe button